hoy es un día muy importante para la
policía porque lograron atrapar a dos
los criminales más peligrosos y más
buscados de la historia el primero de
ellos se llama al manos rojas al y es un
arco traficante y ese mismo día tuvieron
la suerte de atrapar a otro
narcotraficante al cual le vamos a poner
el nombre de bill el tuerto vil ambos se
llevaron por separado al penal y les
dijeron lo siguiente este es un caso
abierto y cerrado al mismo tiempo es un
caso cerrado porque ambos son
narcotraficantes y por la venta de
drogas les vamos a dar una condena de
dos años entonces independientemente ya
los dos tienen una condena de dos años
de prisión por el hecho de vender drogas
pero el problema no termina aquí pues es
detective que está llevando sus casos
sospecha que ambos malhechores
cometieron un crimen más grande juntos
no sé supongamos que robaron un banco
hace un par de semanas pero el problema
es que ninguno de los dos delincuentes
quiere confesar qué fue lo que pasó ni
al civil quieren cooperar con la policía
y entonces para obligarlos a confesar lo
que sucedió en el robo de banco entonces
el detective
se le ocurre hacer la siguiente dinámica
y eso si no vayan a olvidar que tantos
mil como 'la están en celdas separadas
es decir no pueden comunicarse y esto es
importante porque entonces se acerca a
la celda de al iva a intentar encontrar
la forma de que 'la confiese la verdad
entonces le dice lo siguiente lo que ya
estamos seguro escrito ya tienes dos
años de prisión por la venta de drogas
ahora bien lo que te propongo es lo
siguiente si tú confiesas lo que pasó
ese día es decir si decides cooperar con
la investigación civil sigue en su plan
de no cooperar con la investigación es
decir bill no nos dicen nada acerca de
lo que sucedió entonces tú vas a tener
un año de prisión solamente un año te
voy a bajar la condena mientras que bill
le voy a dar diez años de prisión
entonces vamos a notar lo tuvo un año y
el otro diez años
y ojo tanto vil como 'la están en celdas
separadas no se pueden comunicar por lo
tanto hagan con bill y le dicen lo mismo
tú ya tienes dos años de prisión por ser
un narcotraficante y vamos a ser los
siguientes si tú confiesas lo que
sucedió ese día y al no confiesa
entonces a ti te vamos a bajarla
a un año ya le vamos a poner 10 años de
prisión ya está aquí todo pinta bien
de hecho pinta igual para los dos pero
hay que tener cuidado porque si uno de
los dos no confiesa mientras que el otro
sí confiesa entonces tú vas a obtener
diez años de prisión mientras que el
otro va a obtener solamente un año de
prisión como hay que ser justos estos lo
decimos a ambos tanto a bill como al si
tú no confiesa y el otro si confiesa por
lo tanto tú vas a tener diez años de
prisión mientras que el otro solamente
va a tener un año de prisión y bueno no
todos miel sobre ojuelas falta ver qué
es lo que va a pasar si ambos confiesan
es decir si tanto vil como 'la deciden
confesar a bueno si ambos deciden
confesar entonces la dinámica va a ser
la siguiente los dos van a tener tres
años de prisión y bueno aunque los dos
están cooperando no nos podemos bajar a
ambos un año de condena lo que vamos a
ver es aumentarles solamente un año a su
condena debido a que además de que son
narcotraficantes hicieron un robo de
banco así que su condena va a quedar en
tres años a este problema se le conoce
como el famosísimo
del prisionero y bueno lo primero que
nos damos cuenta es que hay un óptimo
cuando los dos tienen dos años de
condena es decir cuando ninguno de los
dos confiesa sería una buena estrategia
que ninguno de los dos confesara sin
embargo hay que tener cuidado porque si
tu compañero confiesa a ti te vas a dar
diez años de prisión y al otro le van a
dar solamente un año de prisión y bueno
estamos suponiendo que los dos este
delincuentes no son hermanos ni mejores
amigos ni nada por lo tanto no hay un
nexo que los une para resolver este
problema voy a hacer una matriz la cual
se conoce como matriz de pagos entonces
estoy poniendo aquí a bill y bill tiene
dos opciones o confesar o no confesar
entonces o confiesa uno confiesa y del
otro lado también voy a poner al y al
también tiene dos opciones o confesar o
no confesar y como es una matriz voy a
hacer sus renglones y sus columnas para
que parezca más matriz muy bien si se
dan cuenta esta matriz tiene los cuatro
escenarios posibles si ambos confiesan
si uno contiene y el otro no confiesa si
uno no confiesa y otro confiesa y si los
dos no confiesan y en esa matriz lo que
vamos a poner son los respectivos pagos
de cada uno de los dos
una de las situaciones por ejemplo en el
primer caso tengo oxide uno confiese y
el otro confiesa ambos tienen tres años
en el segundo cuadro en el cuadro de la
derecha superior
tengo el escenario en el cual al va a
confesar y bill no va a confesar y si
esto sucede
le van a dar un año mientras que a bill
evans a dar diez años bueno vamos al
cuadro inferior izquierdo que va a pasar
aquí es el caso en donde milk confiesa y
al no confiesa por lo tanto a él le van
a dar diez años mientras que hábil por
haber confesado le dan solamente un año
de prisión y ahora vamos a ver el último
cuadro en el último cuadro de los dos no
confiesan entonces ambos les van a dar
dos años de prisión su condena más de
dos años por lo tanto tanto al le van a
dar dos años de prisión como abril le
van a dar dos años de prisión y ya con
esto acabamos nuestra matriz de pago
tenemos los cuatro escenarios posibles
en esta matriz de pago y bueno lo
primero que se ve de nuevo es que si los
dos no confiesan es un punto de
equilibrio y parece ser que ahí los dos
están muy bien sin embargo recuerden que
no hay un nexo de lealtad entre los dos
por lo tanto si yo
delincuente a mí me conviene confesar
porque me bajarían la condena mientras
que el otro le van a aumentar la condena
por lo tanto la mejor estrategia es que
yo confiese y al otro también le
conviene confesar por lo tanto el punto
en donde los dos confesamos es un punto
de equilibrio y se conoce como un
equilibrio de nash un equilibrio de nash
es aquel punto en el cual cada jugador
conoce y ha optado por su mejor
estrategia y todos los jugadores conocen
las estrategias de todos los demás
jugadores otra forma de verlo es la
siguiente un equilibrio de nage es aquel
punto de estrategias tales que si
nosotros cambiamos la estrategia vamos a
obtener un pago menor o igual al pago
que tenemos en el equilibrio de nash una
vez que ya sabemos esto vamos a tratar
de visualizarlo en la matriz de pagos si
yo soy al tengo de dos opciones o que
bill confiese o que bill no confiesen
civil confiesa es muy lógico y es muy
claro que a mí me conviene confesar
civil no confiesa entonces también es mi
mejor estrategia confesar de un año de
prisión a dos años de prisión
yo prefiero un año de prisión entonces
la mejor estrategia va a ser siempre
confesar y de igual manera para vil
si se dan cuenta es una matriz simétrica
por lo tanto me la está pensando en lo
siguiente yo no sé qué es lo que está
pensando al si confesar o no confesar
pero si al confiesa a mi mejor
estrategia es confesar y si al no
confiesa pues mejor estrategia también
es confesar pues en el caso de que al
confiarse yo tengo o tres años de
prisión si confieso o diez años de
presión si no confieso por lo tanto voy
a confesar y si no confiesa en mi mejor
estrategia también es confesar de un año
de prisión a dos años de prisión también
me conviene un año de prisión por lo
tanto sea lo que sea que diga al a mí me
conviene confesar si al confiesa
entonces hábil le conviene confesar y si
hazlo confiesa entonces hábil también
recomienda confesar por lo tanto este
punto en donde los dos confiesan es un
equilibrio de nash en este punto los dos
están jugando sus mejores estrategias y
más aún si alguno decidiera cambiar la
estrategia es decir no confesar por lo
tanto va a perder es justo la definición
de un equilibrio de nash y esto es muy
interesante porque en este caso el
equilibrio de nash contradice al
equilibrio global que hay de esta matriz
de pagos
racionalmente hablando suena muy lógico
que la mejor estrategia es que ninguno
de los dos confiese es decir que los dos
obtengan dos años de prisión en lugar de
los tres años de prisión que están
obteniendo en el equilibrio en h sin
embargo el problema radica en que este
punto de equilibrio es un punto de
equilibrio inestable mientras que el
punto de equilibrio en el equilibrio de
nash es un punto de equilibrio
completamente estable porque fíjense si
yo me paro en el punto de equilibrio
global y estable y además suponemos que
yo soy al entonces yo voy a mejorar mi
pago si yo cambio estrategia de dos años
de prisión a un año de prisión me
conviene más en el prisión por lo tanto
yo voy a confesar y de la misma manera
para bill civil tiene doce años de
prisión o un año de prisión él va a
cambiar su estrategia de no confesar a
confesar y es por eso que nos movemos en
estas direcciones y es por eso que es un
punto de equilibrio inestable porque
conviene a cambiar de estrategia
mientras que en el equilibrio en las
pasa lo siguiente si yo soy vil y estoy
en el equilibrio de nash entonces a mí
no me conviene cambiar estrategia no me
conviene pasar de confesar a no confesar
porque entonces yo perdería por lo tanto
yo no me voy a mover
+ 10 más voy a poner una pequeña flecha
para que vean lo que no voy a hacer
no voy a cambiar la estrategia de
confesar a no confesar y de manera
análoga para al cielo está en el
equilibrio de nash él no va a cambiar
estrategia porque ese cambio de
estrategia va a perder por lo tanto él
siempre va a confesar en lugar de no
confesar tanto al como bill están
optando por su mejor estrategia y es por
eso que este equilibrio de nash es un
punto de equilibrio estable y bueno se
me acabó el tiempo y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo